qué tendrá que hacer Estados Unidos para
reparar las relaciones justamente con
sus aliados que se han visto afectadas
por la filtración esto Podría tener
efectos a largo plazo
sí siempre hay efectos a largo plazo
aquí lo que hay que hacer es una
investigación
concienzuda comprensiva y ver cómo esto
se eligió a los medios
esto salió
preliminarmente ya sabemos que esto
salió del Estado Mayor conjunto que hay
en el pentágono de la oficina
específicamente del j2 de la oficina de
inteligencia donde todo se deposita y
Aparentemente lo que
estoy analizando es que posiblemente hay
una persona
no muy contenta que decidió vengarse
y decidió sacar a flote toda esta
información
Bueno y quién se beneficia con este tipo
de filtración por ejemplo Rusia podría
tomar como fiable estos datos publicados
Y aprovecharlos en la guerra
Rusia puede pensar que esto es una
manipulación y que la información que
está saliendo afuera es es falsa
o puede esa información y
manipularlos ellos Acuérdate que ellos
son ellos tienen un programa que se
conoce como desinformación en un
programa estratégico que ellos cogen una
noticia y la miran patas arriba para
tratar de
de manipular
a la gente a la masa como un intento de
operaciones psicológicas
estratégicas Así que ellos ahora están
tratando Yo sé que Rusia ahora mismo
debe estar tratando de averiguar cuán
cierta es esta información a través de
otros medios que lo puedan comprobar y
si no Y si es cierta pues entonces
tratar de utilizarla para manipularla en
el contexto de de una operación de
operaciones psicológicas